dans le matin glacé du désert libien
Pascal letoubou fait une pause avant une
longue journée de
route comme tous les hommes de sa tribu
il connaî cette mer de sable comme sa
poche indispensable dans son
métier Pascal est un passeur
d'immigré toutes les semaines il conduit
des clandestins qui arrivent de toute
l'Afrique vers le haut comme il dit vers
la Méditerranée
demain matin Pascal et son assistant ont
deux camerounet à convoyer un voyage
périlleux qu'il vaut mieux bien
préparer la voiture doit être en parfait
état pas question de tomber en panne
dans le désert pour conjurer le sort
Pascal a un grriri et pour le moral de
bouteilles de
jeans mais le plus important est d'êre
bien armé depuis la Révolution le
gouvernement libien a du mal à reprendre
le contrôle de son pays il faut pouvoir
se défendre contre les bandits de grand
chemin qui pululent dans le désert ce
sont des
roquettes vos
sécurité Pascal habite la ville la plus
au sud de la Libye
mourzou une oasis de 20000 habitants
depuis la mort de Kaddafi en 2011 la
Libye est devenue le principal corridor
de l'immigration clandestine des
centaines d'Africains illégaux viennent
s'échouer dans ces rues mourzou est une
ville étape les clandestins s'y arrêtent
pour se refaire une santé financière il
gagnent ici quelques centaines d'euros
de quoi payer la suite de leur voyage
vers
l'Europe c'est exactement le parcours
des deux clients de Pascal ce matin
c'est le grand
départ l'assistant du Passeur vient les
réveiller
debout debout
debout Émile 19 ans sans diplôme est
parti de son pays à l'âge de 16 ans
Ellie 24 ans footballeur professionnel
tout deux vont risquer leur vie pour un
rêve rejoindre la France coûte que coûte
leur dangereux périple a commencé en
2010 tous les deux ont quitté leur pays
natal le Cameroun avant de passer par le
Tchad où se sont rencontrés une lente
avancée de 3 ans pour finalement échouer
à mourzou où ils sont devenus maçons
pour payer la suite de leur
voyage en France
Ellie compte bien redevenir le grand
sportif qu'il était dans son pays
comment j'étais footballeur j'ai joué
jusqu'en première division au Cameroun
c'est ça qui me pousse aller en Europe
donc il fallait qu'on trouve un moyen
pour que je sorte du pays et vous savez
les problèmes de visa au Cameroun
surtout pour la France c'est pas c'est
pas très éid moi mon souhait c'est de
faire dans le showb
showsiness c'est ce que moi j'adore le
plus
au après son bac em a fait un stage à la
télécamerounaise réussir dans le showbe
en France est devenu une obsession quand
il parle de Paris il a des étoiles plein
les yeux je vois la France le plus
souvent la
télé des grands immeubles
Chisé des gens sont libres s'expriment
comme ils veulent se promènent comme ils
veulent du travail il y a tout ce que
moi je je veux il y a çab en France donc
je souhaite vraiment y aller après 2 ans
pass à leur deux existences se résument
à cette simple
valise la
mage combattant comme ça toujours été
derère le début c'est de tris fringes
pour la
route
mais allez go ce matin-là ils sourit
mais leur rêve est soudain devenu
terrifiant ils vont affronter 2000 km
d'abord le désert et surtout la mer
Méditerranée qu'ils vont traverser sur
un bateau de
fortune l'assistant de Pascal prend
place à l'arrière
[Musique]
B qui laisse bon santé c'est
ça bonne santé je bonne
santé
descend le long voyage démarre sur les
chapeau de rou car Pascal le passeur est
un peu éméché il multiplie les coups
[Musique]
d'accélérateur
les deux camerounais restent confiant on
est content de partir on est aussi
triste d'avoir la Le Rest de compagnons
on a le temps à passer
[Musique]
ensemble y a la
fiertéiu
tristesse le cœur serré enregistre un
dernier message que l'assistant remettra
au copain rest à Marz chaque fois que tu
auras un problème un événement
malheureux un événement heureux tu peux
compter sur nous som tes frères ce n'est
que la mè qui nous sépare j'espère que
très très bientôt on va se
[Musique]
revoir que Dieu vous garde que Dieu
garde tout le monde on est toujours
ensemble
[Musique]
ok pour atindre
parisesamais prendre des risques
[Musique]
insensés comme Émile et Ellie il seraiit
près de 150000 chaque année à vouloir
franchir les frontières illégalement
pour rejoindre ce qu'il croit être
l'eldorado
européen seul ou en famille ils sont
prêts à prendre tous les risques pour y
arriver quit à perdre la vie ils
viennent d'Afrique et d'Orient pour la
première fois des caméras de télévision
ont suivi pendant un an le parcours
incroyable de
migrant avec Émile et ses compagnons
nous avons franchi les
déserts traverser la Méditerranée sur un
bateau de fortune au fond d'une cale
dans des conditions
inhumaines comme les esclaves
d'autrefois un enfer un enfer plus que
plus que
l'enfer avec Javid lman et leurs amis
afghans nous avons gravi des montagnes
et passé des frontières
interdites croiser des passeurs sans
pitié brave le froid la faim et la
soif il reste combien de montagne à
traverser tout ça tout
ça tous n'atteindront pas la France
c'est leur terrible histoire que nous
allons vous
raconter
dans la voiture qui emmène ell ETM vers
la Méditerranée le mélange estétonnant
musique alcool et pied au plancher lesor
à0
km se coup Pascal la nationale le
goudron comme on dit en
Afrique
il emprinte des pistes que seuls les
hommes du désert connaissent sans lui
c'est la mort
assuré d'ailleurs cette sciance fait sa
renommée mais aussi son prix pour chaque
passager il a empoché 500 € soit 5 fois
le salaire moyen d'un
[Musique]
libien
pour me est énorme mais c'est
l'assurance de ne jamais tomber sur une
patrouille de
police quand on vous AR c'est pas
facile Paris il faut payer Paris on vous
met en prison vous avez peur qu'on vous
attrape oui bien
s c'est pas facile la
torture il leur a fallu 8h pour
parcourir les 150 km de désert entre mou
et
la première étape de leur
voyage ici ils vont récupérer un autre
candidat à l'Europe c'est un ami un
Camerounais comme eux c marque la limite
du territoire de Pascal maintenant c'est
une autre filière qui les prend en main
mais tout ne va pas se passer comme
prévu la ville de S n'est pas totalement
pacifié elle est en proie de violents
combat entre
Milic le passeur qui devait les
récupérer n'est pas là
Ellie angoisse ça lui rappelle les
galères de son premier voyage vers la
Libye on attend on attend là avait des
moments quand on est arrivé à fa on a
attendu le passeur pour la Libye pendant
près d'un mois et demi 6 semaines donc
on attend
mile est
effondré le propriétaire des lieux les
installe dans son
garage pendant ce temps Joseph l'ami qui
part avec eux en Europe vient d'arriver
en
taxi
bonjour Comment ça va ça va très
bien Joseph est maçon lui aussi il s'est
installé à SBA il y a 3 ans aujourd'hui
il tente ce voyage de l'impossible à
cause des combats meurtriers qui
ravagent la ville de
SBA j'ai dit aux amis bon voilà les amis
l'occasion se présente que je puisse
partir le payer dans l'insécurité le
pays est en mouvement chaque jour des
troubles des coups de feu parti par là
et il n'y a pas mieux que sauver sa tête
et sa vie donc le mieux serait de bouger
parce que les choses s'empire de jour en
jour de jour en jour alorsvant vous
étiez où là vous êtes jeis faire les
courses pour les frèr qu' puissent
mettre quelque chose sous la dent ça
fait depuis le matin person a mangé du
pain du Pepsi avant de repartir un des
hommes de Pascal est allé acheter de
quoi dîner il a sur au clandestins
qu'ils reprendront la route sans faute
demain matin malgré le retard tout
semble bien
organisé la nuit n'a pas calmé les
combats bien au contraire il redouble
d'intensité pour ne rien arranger le
thermomètre a plongé il flirte avec les
degr les clandestins ont un chauffage et
quelques couvertures
quelques heures plus tard c'est la panne
d'électricité il fait
froidoid regard m pi j'ai dormis avec
goudass mais ça ne va
pas tellement froid chauffage été par C
de courant et maison en plein déser
c'est facile et le M des
trous le touche à tout moment tu te
réveilles parce que tu es tabassé par le
FO
le lendemain matin les Camerounais sont
désemparé toujours pas de trace du
Passeur
commence à douter sérieusement de sa
filière c'est je je sais vraiment pas ce
qui se passe je pense que le le
peur
il il n'a jamais existé ce passeur don
nous att parler continue le voyage seul
et bien trop dangereux ils n'ont pas
d'autre choix que
d'attendre le propriétaire des lieux
accepte de les héberger mais à une
condition jusqu'à la porte ici on va
fermer jusqu'à vers là quoi de mettre
ici il veut qu'il construise un mur pour
un salaire non négociable 20 € chacun
Émile ne l'entend pas de cette oreille
ce salaire de misère il n'en veut pas
pour lui c'est de l'esclavage
c'est fini comme ça le trava avec bien
je travaille plus tu vas pas travailler
là non non non c'est vrai
ouis pourquoi nous on assez maltraité
comme
ça je lu demande de faire semblant même
s'il ne veut pas travailler qu' fasse
semblant c'est un petit travail par
rapport à ce qu'on a déjà enduré ici on
nous a on nous a bouffer des milliers de
dinars ici tu travailles dans un
chantier pendant 2 mois après on te sort
on demande de [__] le
camp donc il essaie de faire semblant à
contrecœur il se met au travail à cet
instant le moral d'Émile eté Joseph est
au plus bas comment continuer le voyage
sans passeur le défi qui les attend est
énorme à l'autre bout de la planète un
nouveau jour se lève sur Kabou en
Afghanistan Kabou 3 millions d'habitants
pour la plupart des paysans déplacés
épuisés par 30 ans de guerre parmi eux
deux cousins candidats au voyage en
Europe Javid en blanc ran en gris comme
eux 10000 jeunes Afghans tent leur
chance en Europe chaque année en Asie ce
sont les plus nombreux à émigrer vers
Paris ou Londres Javid et son cousin
Rani sont obligés de quitter
l'Afghanistan il nous raconte que dans
leur région ce sont les talibans qui
font la loi et pour sêtre opposé à une
de leur décision leur tête a été mise à
prix je veux aller en
Europe ici je suis en
danger j'ai des problèmes dans ma
province avec les talibans et je ne peux
plus y
retourner alors je me cache ici à
Kabou j'ai peur parce que les talibans
peuvent m'indre
même ici en pleine
ville fils de paysan aisé javidani
aurait les moyens de se payer un billet
d'avion pour Paris mais pour un Afghan
obtenir un visa européen est quasiment
impossible leur seule option fuir le
pays clandestinement ce matin ils ont
rendez-vous avec le chef de la filière
des passeurs d'autres futurs clandestins
sont aussi
présents
moi je vais vous amener sur une route
plutôt tranquille contrairement aux
autres
passeurs je fournis le pain la
nourriture et les
vêtements vous irez de passeur en
passeur tout au long du
parcours je resterai en contact avec eux
ils vous amèneront sain et sauf en Grèce
sans
problème contrairement à l'Afrique les
peurs afghans organisent tout du départ
jusqu'à l'arrivée comme une agence de
voyage une fois l'argent empoché ils ont
une obligation de résultat sauf sur deux
points qu'est-ce qui se passe si on se
fait voler ou
kidnapper si vous mourrez ou si vous
tombez malade moi je ne suis pas
responsable bon pour le voyage vous
allez me payer 7000 dollars allez mon
frère un bon geste fais le nous à 6005
bon ok 6005 mais si en chemin vous
prenez un autre passeur je vous préviens
je ne rembourse pas même avec cette
ristourne 6500 dollars c'est une somme
considérable quand on sait que le
salaire moyen à Kabou ne dépasse pas 100
€ la plupart des clandestins empreunent
pour partir les deux cousins ont de la
chance leur famille P une partie du
trajet mais ça ne suffit pas jvid est
obligé de vendre sa
voiture et elle vaut combien sur le
marché elle est côté 4500 dollars je
crois l'affaire est conclue avec cette
vente les deux cousins vont on payé les
2000 dollars d' compte réclamés par le
passeur le reste de l'argent sera versé
par leur famille au fur et à mesure de
leur avancer vers l'Europe une sécurité
indispensable pour éviter de se faire
arnaquer par la filière avant de quitter
Kabou leur dernier plaisir est de passer
chez leur barbiers les Afghans aiment
porter beau quelles que soi les
[Musique]
circonstances tous les deux sont
célibataires à part leur famille rien ne
les Kabou une ville qu'il espèrent ne
jamais
[Musique]
revoir voilà notre capitale je ne
reviendrai pas là-bas à Paris c'est
propre il n'y a pas de poussière ici on
voit même pas un arm c'est Sabou ne va
pas nous
manquer je ne sais pas comment va se
passer notre voyage il y aura des
chemins dangereux de la marche on va
traverser des forêts des
montagnes ça va être très difficile
[Musique]
le lendemain matin la grande migration
vers Paris
commence comme l'a promis le passeur
tout est bien organisé un minibus
confortable a été affrêé à l'intérieur
30 hommes qui passent pour des touristes
le voyage démarre de façon plutôt
agréable mais tout cela n'est
qu'illusion leur aventure va se
compliquer ils vont parcourir à pied en
voiture et en bateau 7000 K MRE à
travers le Pakistan l'Iran la Turquie et
enfin la
Grèce sur la route il croise deux
blindés américains dernière image de la
guerre et de ses cauchemars pour Javid
Rohani les Américains sont sales et
méchants ils bloque les routes en
prétextant qu'il y a une bombe mais en
réalité il n'y en a pas tout ce qu'ils
font c'est nous
gêné 3h plus tard une file de plusieurs
kilomètres de camion annonce la
frontière avec le Pakistan tousattendent
de passer le
contrôle l'endroit est sulfureux et
particulièrement surveillé c'est le
point de passage de tous les trafics un
nid d'espion ici se crois les services
secrets pakistanais afghans et même la
CIA à la recherche de djihadistes et de
taliban Javid et Rani passent la
frontière à pied nous les filmons
discrètement ce sera la seule frontière
qu'ils franchiront sans stress il n'y a
pas besoin de passeport pour les afghan
se rendant au
[Musique]
Pakistan en 3 jours le petit groupe de
clandestins avale près d'un millier de
kilomètres en bus pour arriver jusqu'à
Laor dernière étape avant d'attaquer les
terribles montagnes
iraniennes même bien organisé ces
voyages illégaux ne se font jamais d'une
traite parfois il faut attendre des
jours ou des mois dans une sombre cache
sans confort cette fois-ci ce n'est pas
le cas à Laor le passeur pakistanais les
a planqués en
ville à l'intérieur la communauté
s'organise chaque une fonction bien
précise les tâches ménagères ne les
empêch pas de rêver ils ont tous une
vision très poétique de la
France à Paris ils aspergent la ville de
parfum c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit il faut fermer les yeux si tu
regardes en l'air tu en prends plein la
tête au début ça va être compliqué
là-bas à Paris
oui c'est toujours compliqué quand on
change de
culture et surtout ça va être vraiment
compliqué d'apprendre
l'égalité il rigole mais il y a une
chose qui les terrorise la traversée de
l'Iran à pied fawad était routier ces
problèmes ont commencé le jour où sa
société a travaillé pour les
Américains considéré comme un traître
par les talibans il a décidé de fuir en
Europe fawad a déjà tenté le voyage mais
il a échoué arrêté en Iran il a été
il est donc le seul à savoir ce qui les
attend dans les
montagnes dis-moi toi qui déjà allé en
Iran la route est si difficile ou c'est
très
dur combien de chance on a d'arriver
là-bas 5 % de chance 5% pas
plus tu peux pas savoir à quel point
c'est difficile ça me fait marrer quand
je vous vois aussi
optimiste
toi tu crois vraiment que ça va être une
promenade de
santé c'est vraiment ce que tu
crois le voyage organisé continue après
l'appartement le passeur leur a acheté
des billets de train pour la frontière
iraniennead ressemble davantage à des
touristes des
clandestins dans le groupe certains ne F
pas les talibans mais les vandettas qui
font des ravages dans le pays
le jeune lman a rejoint le groupe à Laor
une partie de sa famille a été décimé
don son propre père tout ça pour
quelques hectares de
[Musique]
terrain pour nous le voyage s'arrête à
la frontière entrer en Iran
clandestinement pour des journalistes
c'est prendre le risque d'être pris pour
des espions une accusation très grave
qui mène tout droit en prison nous
laissons à Lukman et ses amis une petite
caméra ce sont eux qui vont filmer cette
partie-là du
périple à partir de cet instant le
voyage prend une autre tournure le
pickup a remplacé le minibus mais
l'ambiance reste
légère je meurs je meurs on est 30 assis
dans ce pickup et il y en a trois si sur
ma
jambe 30 personnes 36
même tassé dans ce pickup ils n'ont pas
encore conscience de ce qui les
attend cette épopée ils l'ont filmé de
bout en bout à travers les montagnes du
balucistan et ces dizaine de Coles à
plus de 3000 m et surtout l'impitoyable
désert de Makran 2000 km à travers
l'Iran pour rejoindre Mia à la frontière
turque tout cela en évitant
soigneusement les villages et les
patrouilles de
police
ça
va oui ça va ça va on commence juste le
voyage que Dieu nous
protège on est nombreux ici on est quand
même plus de
100 160 exactement ce n'est pas par
hasard s'il y a autant de clandestins
pour rentabiliser le voyage plusieurs
réseau se regroupe comme ça il mutualise
la nourriture et les planes pour dormir
maintenant on doit escalader cette
montagne vous avez vu combien on
est cette première ascension leur donne
vite une idée de l'effort à fournir dans
les prochains
[Applaudissements]
jours allez les gars là on avance on
avance je suis mort de fatigue mort de
fatigue ça fait 5 he qu'on marche allez
dépêche-toi avance on va être en
retard Javid aperçoit le sommet il croit
dur comme faire que de l'autre côté
c'est enfin l'Iran pour tous les
migrants le choc va être
[Musique]
brutal
il reste combien de montagnes à
traverser tout ça tout
ça on est encore au Pakistan ou déjà en
Iran au Pakistan en descendant là-bas
c'est toujours le Pakistan jusque
là-bas c'est le Pakistan ouais je
t'assure c'est
là-bas et après c'est l'Iran c'est ouais
[Musique]
ouais après de jours de marche
harassante les voici enfin en
[Musique]
Iran rien n'indique la frontière si ce
n'est la plaque de ce vieux camion
c'est le ravitaillement à cours de vivre
les Afghans sont rassurés mais la
surprise est amère contrairement à ce
qu'avait promis leur passeur tout est
payant et les prix sont exorbitants les0
clandestin n'ont pas le choix ce
raquette ne sera pas le dernier du
[Musique]
voyage le groupe de clandestin passe à
la latitude de bande d'arabas tout près
du Gol
mais ils ne verront jamais la
mer il ne travers que des gorges
encaissées chauffé à blanc par le
soleil un four à ciel
ouvert les jours les plutôt rides la
température peut atteindre 47
deg lman le plus jeune des Afghans
commence à regretter d'avoir quitté son
[Musique]
paysoutenable il nous
tue et on va continuer comme ça jour et
[Musique]
nuit au moins 18h sans
s'arrêter pas le temps de manger boire
ou même
d'uriner c'est vraiment une très longue
[Musique]
marche il n'est pas le seul à se
plaindre aussi très en colère contre les
passeurs comment se passe le voyage
c'est tout pourri [__] de
passeur il nous avait assuré qu'on
marcherait au maximum pendant 1
heure mais là ça fait 8h qu'on crap à et
malheureusement c'est toujours pas
fini les passeurs vous ne les verrez
jamais il ne se laissent pas filmer ils
ouvrent la marche d'un pas militaire et
tant pis pour les traînard comme
pourant s'éloigner du groupe c'est aussi
risqu sa
vie faut se
dépêcherut rester au milieu du
groupe en plus la nuit approche et c'est
pas bon il y a des
voleurs oui je pense qu'il y en a ils
ont l'habitude de voler l'argent les
sacs et même les
chaussures lman ont atteint un point de
non retour perdu au milieu de nulle part
il leur est impossible de faire machine
arrière maintenant il faut qu'ils
regardent droit devant vers la frontière
turque à plus de 1500
[Musique]
km en Libye le moral est au plus bas
pour les trois camerounais le passeur
n'est toujours pas là et le mur qu'ils
construisent pour payer leur séjour est
bientôt
terminé le propriétaire risque de les
mettre à la
porte alors Joseph va prendre leur
destin en main oui bon jour comment va
la matinée voilà ça va bien ok tu es
dans ton lieu de service Joseph a des
connexionsok plusieurs amis à lui ont
déjà organisé des
[Musique]
traversées
après des dizaines de coups de
téléphone et des heures de prière ce
matin éternel tu nous entends au nom du
Père du Fils et du
saintespr le miracle arrive
enfin allô Joseph a trouvé un nouveau
passeur promet de les emmener sans
encombre jusqu'à la mer ou donc le
départ c'est PRU don ce soir
ok encore une fois ils refont valise
commune et avant de partir le
propriétaire des lieux le verse le
salaire 160 dinar li soit les 20 €
promis pour chacun d'ux
1200 140 150
155 mais il y a un problème les nouveaux
passeurs refusent d'être suivis par des
journalistes ils ne peuvent pas courir
le risque de nous mélanger à de nous
mélanger à vous donc ils ont décidé que
on puisse prendre notre véhicule et vous
vous allez trouver votre moyen de
transport de moyen de de un moyen pour
vous retrouver à Tripoli bon nous on
partira troit de notre côté nous filons
donc par la route principale les
attendre à Tripoli la capitale libyenne
700 km plus au
[Musique]
nord eux vont prendre un autre chemin
une fois de plus il passe par le désert
et des routes secondaires dans de vieux
pickup mais aussi à
pied puis tout dérape les passeurs se
comportent en torionnaire la souffrance
des trois camerounais va durer 6 jours
au lieu des deux
prévu nous avons suivi leur calvaire par
téléphone
combien de changements de passeur et
d'étapes vous avez fait depuis CBAS nous
sommes au 5e on attend le 6e là
maintenant vous avez C vous avez changé
cinq fois de passeur CIN fois le passeur
oui on est en train de passer par le
désert toujours par le désert par les
chambres on nous dépose à un endroit un
chauffeur vient nous prendre il nous
dépose donc là vous êtes à combien de
kilomètres de Tripoli nous sommes à 650
c'est ce que le dernier passeur vient de
nous dire là donc vous avez à peine fait
100 km
ouais
les passeurs les
maltraitent et quand ils osent se
plaindre parfois on est battu parfois on
est battu le sac de Joseph aussi je vous
disais qu'il était le seul à garder son
sac actuellement son sac aussi on l'
jeté donc vous avez plus rien là on a
plus rien rien pas de sousvêtement rien
pas de rien rien rien ils vous ont volé
ça i Il on pris l'argent que vous avez
gagné assez bas vous
trouvé
où une semaine plus tard nous les rrou à
Tripoli ils on ét recueillis par la
communauté
camerounaise ils ont perdu du poid on
dirait des
fantômes
ok voici leur récit on est fatigué
c'était très dur oua ouais très dur très
dur on nimaginait pas ça comme ça dans
tous les
cas se voyait en route têre maximum pour
2 jours peut-être 3 jours mais pas
jusqu'à 6 jours avec tout ce qu'on a
enduré comme difficulté comme
torture parce que là c'était vraiment la
torture un enfer un enfer plus que plus
que
l'enfer parce que je n'ai jamais vu
depuis la naissance depuis ma naissance
je n'ai jamais vu des choses aussi aussi
horrible il y a des gens qui pleurent
des gaillards des papas qui pleurent à
chaude larme et quand tu te mets à
pleurer il passe avec le bâton au-dessus
de la couverture il tape fort un gros
bâton comme ça il tape fort une trait
d'esclave ditcoute ferme là esclave à un
moment donné nous sommes arrivés il nous
a parqué quelque
part pas de nourriture pas
d'eau je sors dans ma bible pour prier
le gar il me voit avec la Bible il
demande qu'est-ce que tu es en train de
faire esclave il vient il me tabasse il
arrache ma Bible il la
jette les mois résistants sont
abandonnés purement et simplement dans
le
désert c'est c'est ce qui est arrivé à
ces migrants qui ont trouvé la mort à la
frontière entre la Libye et
l'Algérie pour Émile ce voyage restera
gravé à jamais dans sa
mémoire il a aidé à marcher puis
porortait un homme à bout de force sur
près de 2 km mais à un moment donné il
ne pouvait même plus parler me disait
seulement que aide-moi aide-moi le gars
est tombé je suis en train de soulever
le gars il pèse plus que moi je mets la
main ici sur le cou du gars ça ne bat
plus je mets la main sur le cœur ça ne
bat plus j'ai dit à l'AR que le gars est
mort il me dit s'il est mort tire au sol
il dit non moi je peux pas le tirer
comme ça c'est quand même un mort on
doit le respectecter il m'a dit si tu ne
veux pas le tirer il m'a mis le fusil
ici sur la tête je lui ai dit que je ne
peux
pas il a commencé à me taper avec le
fusil il crachait sur moi et tout et
tout et tout et tout ils ont porté le
gars ils ont mis Lab je sais pas comment
ils ont fait avec lui je n'ai aucune
idée de ce qu'ils ont fait avec lui
aucune
idée mais au bout de toutes ces
souffrances une
récompense voir enfin la Méditerranée
[Musique]
elle est toute bleue là elle est belle
TR B la couleur du CI les uvres de Dieu
sont
magnifiques et ça c'est la dernière
étape leur dernier défi est devant eux
de l'autre côté il y a l'Europe cette m
il faut maintenant la
traverser cela fait près de 3 ans qu'ils
ont laissé le Cameroun derrière eux
chacun se prend à rêver Joseph pense
qu'il a de l'or dans les mains il est
sûr que son talent fera Merve en
France les gens disent que je suis un
génie dans la décoration je peux devenir
un artiste côté décoration on ne sait
jamais malgré ses 19 ans
ile a des rêves plus
sages mon rêve c'est de réussir avoir
une maison des
enfants une femme je sais qu'en Europe
c'est la galère pour les 100 papiers et
je sais aussi que il y a ce qui sont
allés ils étaient sans papiers
aujourd'hui ils ont des papiers donc
pourquoi pas moi pour Ellie ce voyage
est une revanche c'est avant tout pour
faire ses preuves qu'il l'a
entamé dans ma famille il y a beaucoup
qui n'ont pas cru en moi j'ai tout faire
pour qu'elle sache que peut-être ma
réussite c'est-être l'autre côté de de
la Méditerranée je sais que je suis fort
physiquement fort mentalement en Europe
il y a beaucoup de d'ouverture parce que
je me dis que les la chance que j'ai pas
pu avoir en Afrique au Cameroun plus
précisément peut-être de l'autre côté je
pourrais l'avoir pour eux c'est l'ultime
étape avant Paris pourtant leurs galères
sont loin d'être terminées traverser la
Méditerranée est hors de prix même sur
un bateau de fortune or ils sont ruinés
les passeurs leuront pris toutes leurs
économies ils vont devoir travailler sur
des chantiers à
zoira nous sommes en janvier nous les
retrouverons dans 5 mois
c'est du port de zoara à 100 km de
Tripoli que partent la majorité des
bateaux
d'illégaux été comme hiver la ville est
envahie de
clandestin tous ne survivront pas cette
traversée vers l'île italienne de
Lampedusa 250 km de mer qui s'effectue
sur des bateaux de pêche comme
celui-ci prévu pour quelques marins les
passeurs y entassent des centaines
d'immigrés afin de faire un maximum de
profit toutes les semaines les
militaires ramassent sur les plages de
zoira les corords des suppliciers
rejetés par la
mer de
africainosserici de l'Europe tombé dans
la mer il va s dire d'ici avant hier il
trouvé CIN personnes ici aussi
aujourd'hui tu es un petit garçon mais
pas mais
pas 6 ans ou 7 ans M pas
ça 5 mois plus tard
Émile Joseph et elle ont gagné assez
d'argent pour traverser la
Méditerranée ils nous ont
téléphoné nous les retrouvons
le dernier chantier on est presque au
bout
donc on est bien on essaie de travailler
au maximum parce qu'il faut pas juste
payer le transport pour laousa il
faut d'argent de
pocheara rien de plus facile que de
rencontrer des passeurs il y en a à tous
les
Carrefour et ce sont souvent eux qui
démarch les
clandestins
Joseph et on rendez-vous avec l'un
d'entre eux ils vont négocier leur
passage mais aussi le NRE nous FM la
rencontre en camé caché le passur c'est
C HME de dos à la casquette et téléphone
rose amis qui veulent traverser il onel
hier il cher une bonne filière pour
passer il sont 5
les trois camerounais plus
nous combien vous pouvez
mettre 600
800 € ok je réfléchis donne-moi ton
numéro après plusieurs jours de
négociation ils finissent par s'entendre
sur un
prix ce sera 900 € par journaliste et
600 € pour chacun des
Camerounais la casè d'Alibaba maintenant
on détaille nos économies vois c'est
demain de s je détaille mon argent notre
argent de mois n économie ce qu'on a
prévu pour le
voyage combien
345 cet argent c'est la chur de mon
frond je l'ai bien travaillé je le
mérite très bien je mérite plus que ça
on a Cavaillé nous a pas tout payé avec
la souffrance qu'on a injuré ici bon ça
ça nous reconforte quand même un peu
parce que ça peut nous payer le
transport jusqual si jamais monter sur
un bateau la première fois tuas pas trop
peur si j'ai peur mais pas trop la htise
du naufrage est dans toutes les têtes
surtout qu'ils ne savent pas sur quelle
embarcation ils vont
voyager certaines traversées se font sur
des coquilles de noix comme
cell-là
début octobre TR bateaux on sombré dont
un avec 500 personnes à bord en 2 ans
3600 clandestins on trouvé la mort en
mer le risque est immense mais la
promesse d'une vie meilleure en Europe
est plus forte que
tout de jours plus tard le moment tant
attendu est
arrivé ils sont convoqués sans bagage
sur une plage au nord de
zoira Émile comme les autres retient son
souffle le bruit pourrait les signaler
au policiers qui patrouill après une
heure d'attente le signal est
donné les dizaines de migrants prennent
d'assaut les petites embarcations des
[Musique]
passeurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelques minutes plus tard il les presse
de grimper à bord d'un bateau beaucoup
plus
gros les migrant ne voit rien ne savent
pas combien ils sont une seule certitude
maintenant ils sont livrés à
[Musique]
eux-mêmes il y a de la peur puisque déjà
bon on ne sait pas si le capitaine est
compétent nous ne savons d'où il vient
on ne sait pas si c'est un un capitaine
confirmé sur le pont cette femme
enceinte se sent déjà mal et son voyage
n'a pas commencé
[Musique]
à 5h du matin l'aube leur permet de
découvrir l'embarcation et leur
compagnons
d'infortune au total ils sont
260 parmi eux des héritréens des
Somaliens des
[Musique]
libi à bord devant le danger les
différences religieuses s'effassent
chacun s'en remet à son
[Musique]
Dieu Joseph cherchee et Émile ils ont
été séparés à
l'embarquement je suis en train de
chercher un passage pour qu'on puisse
trouver mes deux frères en
[Musique]
bas mais la calavant est
inaccessible il n'y a pas possibilité de
pénétrer pénétrer il y a trop de monde
l'endroit est bouché complètement
bouché nous parvenons néanmoins à
descendre par la trappe
arrière le pire endroit du bateau une
centaine de clandestins s'y entassent
les uns sur les autres il règne une
odeur insoutenable et la chaleur est
suffoquante il n'y a aucun souffle
d'air le bruit assourdissant du moteur
casse les
[Applaudissements]
têtes
c'est vraiment chiant ici
franchement je n'arrive même plus à
respirer je suis pas àaise il fait
tellement
chaud il y a des bomissements partout
ici lesjà on eu des vertig ont vomit et
franchement ça dégage je suis mal à
l'aise mais j'ai pas de choix une heure
après le départ les passeurs ont
organisé un petit- déjeuner
frugal
distribution d'eau de pain et de
[Musique]
fromage les visages se
dérident ils ne le savent pas encore
mais ce sera leur seul repas pendant la
[Applaudissements]
traversée pas sûr que les danés de la
cale eux est le cœur à
[Musique]
manger à bord tout le monde n'a pas payé
le même prix
Ellie et Émile ont versé 600 € mais
d'autres ont versé des sommes
faramineuses comme ce père de famille
souanais pris en charge par les passeurs
depuis
de Tripoli à lampeda moi j'ai payé 1400
dollar par
personne pour nous TR pour moi ma femme
et la petite
a j'ai payé00
[Musique]
dollaretutre diff tous se sont ruinés
pour la même
raison on le sait que c'est
risqué mais si on est tous là c'est pour
enfin avoir quelque chose à manger dans
nos
assiettes pour les passeurs ce trafic
est très rentable d'après nos
estimations les 260 migrants ont
rapporté à la filière près de 200000 €
et pourtant à bord pas un seul gilet de
sauvetage ni aucune fusée de détresse en
cas de naufrage
pour sorienter le capitaine ne possède
que le strict minimum une boussole et un
GPS grand
public le bon cap grâce à ce petit GPS
et cette
boussole pour le moment tout va
bien l'ampedusa est encore loin il le
reste 12 he de
navigation et le pire est encore à
venir
[Musique]
dépêche-toi tu es toujours le
dernier de leur côté les Afghans
Javid
fawad
Rani et lman ont bien avancé en
Iran ils ont parcouru 3500 km
il TR maintenant dans la région
iranienne de Far au centre du pays ils
sont
ex les impito imp CAD Infern plus vite
le groupeve àtination plus vite pour
aller en chercher un autre au 7 jour de
marche comm àquer
50 60
montagnes ça
continue
à ce stade de la marche les muscles
deviennent douloureux les articulations
souffrent R n peut
plus mes jambes me font très
mal endroit est très
difficile d'autant qu'aucun clandestin
n'est réellement équipé pour une marche
aussi longue beaucoup sont en chaussur
de ville ou en basquet de mauvaise
qualité Javid lui souffre depuis
plusieurs heures ses chaussures
pakistanaises se sont désintégré sur les
rochers ce sont les chaussures
Pakistan ces pieds ne sont pas en
meilleur
état on n pas pu se laver on est très
sale regarde un peu mes
chaussettes as vu le pied
de
tu as vu son
ampoule ces épreuves n'empêch pas la
solidarité entre marcheurs
clandestins depuis une heure ce vieil
homme souffre le martyre à chaque pas et
c'estvid qui va le
soigner tu es tombé
oui ça te fait mal oui ça me fait très
très
mal prévoyantvid a emporté une petite
trousse de
secours ser le bandage
davantage ce sera plus
[Musique]
efficace tu peux marcher baba ou que
quelqu'un reste à ses
côtés après la fatigue l'autre ennemi
c'est la déshydratation on a soif
tellement
soif chacun porte une bouteille mais
quand elle est vide les Afghans
dépendent des trous d'eau croisé au
hasard de la
marche
la plupart du temps c'est une e
[Applaudissements]
sale mais il n'hésite pas à y plonger
leur
bouteille au risque de tomber
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
malade tu as soif oui j'ai très soif
mais il n'y a pas d'eau en si il y en a
mais elle est sale et on a besoin de
boire alors elle a quel goût
elle est vraiment infecte
Javid a trouvé une astuce peut-être pas
très efficace mais
simple il filtre l'eau avec son
[Musique]
foulard au 10 jour de marche la colonne
des0 clandestins s'ére et fin par se
disloquer
[Musique]
certains sont à la traain épuisés par la
fatigue il n'arrivve même plus à
rattraper le
groupe S camarades
[Musique]
sécou on est fatigué on est trop
fatigué des gens sont restés loin
derrière
ils sont nombreux à la
traain un Pakistanais salement amoché
s'il reste là tu crois qu'il va
mourir bien s qu'il va
mourir et to tu derrière les branches
comment tu te sens je me sens pas
bien à partir de chir la frontière
turque est encore à 1000 km mais une
surprise les
attend certaines portions du trajet vont
se faire en
voiture 30 km ici 20 km là de
gagner puis retour à
l'effort je ne comprends pas pourquoi
ils nous ont fait descendre du camion
ils nous font passer par ailleurs
peut-être que la route est
bloquée depuis qu'ils sont en Iran ils
alternent les bivoic en pleine
montagne loin des repas promis par les
[Musique]
passeurs ne mange surtout pas il est
moisi tu vas être
malade et les planques pas forcément
plus
confortable il fait une chaleur c'est
horrible nous ont forcé à sortir et à
rester
dehors une chaleur de dingue qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire maintenant
il fait tellement chaud ça me
tue nai rien à boire avec ce gâteau pas
d'eau ça reste collé dans ma gorge c'est
pas
[Applaudissements]
terrible
ces caches ont un avantage elles ont
l'électricité ce qui leur permet de
recharger leur téléphone et c'est loin
d'être un
luxe bizarrement les guides abandonnent
parfois les clandestins en le indiquant
juste la direction à suivre quand le
groupe se perd c'est la panique comme ce
jourlvid
passeurous je vousonce à la
police va te faire
voir il a dit qu'il nous envoyait
quelqu'un dans 20
minutes c'est ce qu'il vient de me
dire il nous dit ça depuis des
HE les Télécom Iraniens sont plutôt
performants il y a du réseau dans toutes
les
montagnes
passé térant la capitale iranienne il
file droit vers la Turquie entassé dans
une vieille Peugeot certains sont même
enfermés dans le
coffre nous sommes à la mi-mai ils ont
quitté l'Afghanistan il y a un mois et
ils atteignent maintenant les montagnes
du Kurdistan qui les séparent de la
Turquie nous les retrouvons à cette
étape et reprenons le fil du
tournage ici les paysages tranchent avec
les montagnes pelées du centre de l'Iran
place aux alpages et au climat
frais les passeurs ont prévu des
vêtements chauds pour les Afghans les
gâteaux ne sont plus moisis ils
retrouvent visage humain ce jour-là tous
se font aussi chic que
possible séance photo improvisé le
passeur local a préparé des demandes
d'asile turqu avec de faux noms il n'y a
plus qu'à coller les
photos regarde c'est
drôle maintenant je m'appelle
amidarm s'il y a des contrôles de police
grâce à ces
papiers on va pouvoir rejoindre istanbou
tranquillement leur traversée est prévue
dans 10
jours là-bas c'est la montagne où on
doit passer la
frontière derrière la chaîne du
Kurdistan c'est la Turquie la porte de
l'Europe mais pour l'atteindre ils vont
devoir affronter le froid et la
neige 3è heure de souffrance pour les
260 clandestins
africains au fond de la cale Émile ne se
sent pas
bien
Ie de son côté réussit à s'extraire de
cet
enfer Joseph lui a fait une petite place
à côté de
[Musique]
lui j'ai le cœur le ventre quionne j'ai
le cœur qui qui va de haut en
bas donne l'envie de vomir mais j'ai pas
encore vomi tout le monde là-bas vom
depuis
[Musique]
trois fois deux fois moi j'ai pas encore
vouu j'ai même pas mangé j'arrive
j'arrive à rien
avaler Joseph vérifie que son agenda
très spécial n'a pas été
effacé il a mis les pieds dans l'eau
avant de monter sur le
bateau ce sont des libi les numéros de
téléphone que j'ai que j'ai marqué là
parce que les libiens les passeurs
prennent tous les téléphones et les SIM
cards donc je l'ai pressenti j'ai écrit
tous les numéros j'ai copié tous les
numéros
[Musique]
là le capitaine vient d'annoncer que l'
Vienne c'est terminé il VI d'annoncer il
y a 30
secondes bon nouvelle une bonne nouvelle
allez
by d'un seul coup tout devient possible
mais rares sont les bateaux qui
dépassent les EAU
territoriales à la 5è heure de traversée
le son assourdissant du moteur se
ta une odeur inqu se répand sur le
pont les brûl qu'il est en train
d'enlever là-bas quelque chose se brûler
dedans c'est une pièce du moteur qui a
pris
feu sont des choses qui arrivent c'est
la machine il vont dépanner et puis on
vaartir
reste philosophe contrairement à la
femme
enceinte c'est une sale journée si le
bateau prend feu on va tous mourir mais
tais-toi
tais-toi je ça sert à rien de
paniquer notre notre notre vie dépend de
lui non on est obligé de lui faire
confiance une demi-heure plus tard le
moteur
repart mais l'incident a marqué les
esprits une certaine tension règne
désormais à
bord ce jeune libien ne supporte plus
les allées venu de certains passagers il
tente l'intimidation puis se lève
menaçant au retour il manque de blesser
la passagère
enceinte c'est à cause de ceux qui sont
devant ça
suffit
[Musique]
à la 12e heure de
navigation un hélicoptère de la sécurité
civile italienne les
surv un premier signe ils vont peut-être
pouvoir tourner le dos à leur ancienne
vie de
[Musique]
misère é fonctionnaires ou même
militaires des postes privilégiés dans
leur pays mais qui leur permettaiit
pourtant tout juste de
survivre n'imaginez pas un institcteur
ou un professeur ou un un un un un
militaire en train de gagner 7 dollars
par mois mais 7 dollars ça représente
[Musique]
quoiésente 7 dollars comment quelqu'un
va vivre avec 7 dollars si on donne 7
dollars sa pas moi à un bel
il y a le siège de l'Union européenne
qui crée t les lois pour bloquer
l'immigration o VI par mois qu'est-ce
qui va faire avec C
[Musique]
dollar prévenu par la sécurité civile la
marine italienne
intervient immédiatement le capitaine du
navire lâche la barre l'armée prend des
photos et s'il est identifié comme tel
laction est
automatique j'ai d le captaine du bateau
se protège parce qu'il sait que si si à
la ré c'est que c'est lui qui pilot le
bateau c'est la prison direct pour lui
chaque passage hélicoptère il lâche
là-bas c'est comme si c'est tout le
monde qui qui pilotait c'est n'importe
qui il est juste là comme comme un
simple
passager 20 minutes plus tard un
bâtiment militaire italien vient à la
rencontre les migrants s'énerv ils sont
restés assis et comprimés pendant plus
de 10 he le libien qui jou du couteau
cherche encore une fois la
[Musique]
bagarre combien y a-t-il
d'enfants des femmes
enceintes des gilets de sauvetage au cas
où un clandestin tomber à l'eau dans la
[Musique]
bousculade ne vous inquiétez pas ne vous
inquiétez pas il y en aura pour tout le
monde il y en aura pour tout le
[Musique]
mondezv
asseyez-vous rapproche-toi rapproche-toi
vas-y envoie la
corde le transbordement des Africains va
durer des
heures les Camerounais sont les derniers
à monter à
[Musique]
bord Joseph Ellie etmile respir
ils ont vaincu la
Méditerranée quand ils touchent enfin le
sol de
Lampedusa 21 he se sont écoulées depuis
leur départ de
Libye leur voyage vers Paris est loin
d'être
terminé pour atteindre la capitale il va
falloir qu'il s'échappe de l'île de
Lampedusa cela fait 20 ans que l'île
toute proche des côtes tunisiennes et
libyennes est la cible des migrants
africains dans le port le cimetière des
rafiot clandestins témoigne des arrivées
massives en 2013 15000 personnes
auraient cherché à débarquer à
[Musique]
Lampedusa les trois Camerounais sont
recillis dans ce camp spécialement
construit par l'État italien
prévu pour 250 personnes il en accueille
aujourd'hui plus d'un millier et l'été
quand la mer est calme l'afflux de
migrants est tel qu'ils sont obligés de
dormir
dehors logiquement
Émile Joseph et Ellie devraiit y rester
au minimum un an le temps que leur
demande d'asile soit examiné si elle est
rejeté ils seront renvoyés au
Cameroun mais un événement imprévu va
bousculer leur
destin début juillet le pape François se
rend à Lampedusa à célébrer une messe à
la mémoire des migrants morts en mer
avant son arrivée une partie du camp est
vidée pour éviter les
débordements les camerounais et d'autres
clandestins sont évacués par avion en
Sicile dans un autre camp de rétention
caramineo un ancien lotissement pour
militaire américain de
l'OTAN il est lui aussi
surpeuplé 4000 migrants pour 1500
[Musique]
places la caméra n'est pas la bienvenue
pour retrouver Ellie et
josephut solution que d'entrer
clandestinement de
nuit une fois à l'intérieur nous sommes
accueillis par le chef de la communauté
camerounaise il nous fait visiter une
petite ville avec ses cybercafés ses
épiceries ses lieux de prostitution les
migrants sont tous dans la même galère
et pourtant les nationalités ne se
mélangent pas les tensions sont même
fréquentes entre elles les Carabin
italien s'en lave les mains il y a
jamais de gendarme qui patrouille il
patrouill mais ils ne font pas leur
travail quoi il ne met aucun contrôle il
passe là pour rien il y a les bagares
ils ne font rien ils ne font absolument
rien chaque quartier est occupé par une
communauté Robert nous emmène dans la
maison où vivent les
Camerounais à l'intérieur l'ambiance
semble sympathique il n'y a pas de
meuble mais il y a de quoi trinquer
[Musique]
ce Joseph Émile et Ie sont effondrés il
ne partage pas l'enthousiasme
général c'est insupportable cet endroit
il y a pas moins de 10 personnes qui
habitent par maison alors que c'est un
logement de CRE TR
personnes est dans maison il est presque
minuit mais les gens ne dorment pas les
gens marchent à partout la maison c'est
la boutique c'est le bar c'est la c'est
la maison à on dort qu'est-ce que vous
voulez Joseph est révolté il s'attendait
à un autre accueil on ne leur sert qu'un
repas par
jour que quelqu'un doit
manger est-ce que c'est normal pour une
immigrée de manger
ceci si c'est de cette façon qu'on
traite les immigrés ici en Italie
vraiment c'est c'est lamentable c'est
vraiment lamentable n'écoute pas les
jalouxcout
T c'est vrai que au Cameroun aime le CH
quand ils ont faim une seule solution la
boutique de MAM
Véronique qu'est-ce que tu fais ici je v
je me
débrouille pour ne pas chômer pour ne
rien ne pas rester sans rien faire je
m'occupe un peu m Véronique fait ses
courses dans le village d'à côté car
tous ont le droit de sortir du camp dans
la journée avec une obligation revenir
le soir donc je vais acheter ça je viens
je détaille encore petit à petit pour
avoir au moins 1 € par paquet
donc c'est les Africains qui achètent si
je ne fais pas ça la viille du Campo va
m'obliger à me prostituer et comme je ne
veux pas me prostituer je suis obligée
de faire un petit truc pour prendre le
temps en attendant que les
papi obtenir un titre de séjour est loin
d'être simple mieux vaut venir d'un pays
en guerre ou être persécuté sinon c'est
l'expulsion et retour à la case despart
mais les commissions d'examen sont
débordées et les réponses arrivent
parfois des mois voire des années après
dans les nombre de choses l'immigré doit
faire 6 mois dans le camp avant de
passer à la commission mais quand lui va
à 2 ans ce n'est plus normal fait 2 ans
qu'il attend la Commission on l'a jamais
appelé aucun des camerounais ne veut
attendre aussi longtemps ils vont filer
à l'anglaise oui moi j'ai pris ma
décision moi me
bat tu comprends non je me B aussi a
pris sa décision il se B mais le ce
barrer
là ça doit
être en âme et conscience c'est un
chemin de non retour qu'on va
prendre je peux pas rester ici dans la
mer le problème qui est là c'est que on
a engagé une procédure concernant la
résidence je préfère s papier ma vi que
de passer 2 ans dans ce C peut-être
c'est là que je vais mourir je vais me
transformer peut-être devenir un
criminel donc m je sois dehors dans le
noir que de rester dans ce
[Musique]
Javid Lukman et Rani se reposent à
Istanbul depuis près d'une
semaine leur visage est maintenant
détendu pourtant ils sont arrivés en
piteuse état le passage entre l'Iran et
la Turquie n'a pas été une partie de
[Musique]
plaisir
le groupe d'Afghans a dû batailler avec
la pluie la neige et le
[Musique]
froid leur prochaine destination la
Grèce ils vont la rejoindre à bord d'un
bateau de
[Musique]
clandestin avant de risquer leur vie en
mer ils ouvrent grand leurs yeux sur
Istanbul un choc culturel
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que les Afghans
voi des femmes qui ne sont pas couvertes
de la tête au pied et osent montrer
autant leur
[Musique]
corps tu as vu les filles sont habiller
super légèrement
ici chez nous les femmes ne peuvent pas
s'habiller comme ça parce Afghanistan on
a la
[Musique]
chariab
il y aura des réaction très
violentes sont avant tout des
montagnards des paysans qui n'ont jamais
vu la
mer la traverser vers les grec à tout
pour les
inquiéter c'est la première fois que je
vois la
mer ça l'air très profond c'est
terrifiant
j'ai très peur de
l'eau mais demain on prend le bateau pas
le
choix n pas d'autre
Chem le 22 mai il quitte istanbou caché
dans un minibus four par la filière des
passeur
direction célèbre station balnéaire dans
l'ouest de la
[Musique]
turquieanist plan bien huilé va mal
tourner alors qu'il se dirige à pied
vers le point de rendez-vous avec le
passeur ils vont se faire surprendre par
la police tur nous les retrouvons juste
après leur débandade au total la police
a arrêté 50 clandestins ils ne sont plus
qu'une
dizaine on va rester ici jusqu'à ce soir
ça craint
rien le passeur a été
arrêté ils sont livrés à eux-mêm
paniqué Javid appelle le chef de la
filière en
Turquie si on trouve un taxi on retourne
à istanbou ou à
couch allez on commence à aller vers
couch après il nous
rappelleouch ils seront pris en main par
un nouveau
passeur jours plusard
c'est la grande
traversée comme les Africains les
Afghans s'apprêtent à prendre la mer
cette fois-ci ce n'est pas l'Italie qui
est visé mais la
Grèce sur la plage tout le monde se tait
un silence si profond que l'on entend
même les
moustiques salé de
moustique
là on n plus très loin de la frontière
grecque par la
mer la frontière est au milieu de la
grande
mer on va traverser cette étendue à bord
d'un petit
bateau on est peut-être 35 on va se
retrouver sur ce petit
bateau c'est très
dangereux le signal est donné
ils embarquent sur un bateau gonflable
poussé par un simple moteur de 15
chevaux direction l'île grec de Samos
dont on aperçoit les lumières juste à 1
km de
là à bord tout sévite de bouger
l'embarcation est tellement petite
qu'elle pourrait
chavirer à cause du poids l'eau
s'infiltre mais Javid ne s'affole pas sa
peur de la mer n'est plus un problème
[Musique]
moi je n'ai peur que d'une seule
chose c'est
deieu soudain il se retrouve pris dans
les phares des gardescôtes
Grecs logiquement les policiers
devraient leur venir en aide mais ce
soir-là ils vont se montrer
cruels les gardescôtes prent le moteur
et les repous dans les EAU
[Musique]
turques à la dérive ils sont maintenant
à la merci d'une mauvaise
vague les policiers nous ont pris le
moteur et l'essence et ils nous ont
abandonné les sales grec ils nous ont
pourri notre voyage et en plus ils nous
ont
abandonn sans moteur l'embarcation estue
instable balloté par les vagues les 35
naufragés ont
[Musique]
peur le petit pneumatique dérive au gré
des
[Musique]
courants résigné les clandestin se
mettent à fumer à l'inverse de tout à
l'heure il cherche à se faire repérer
lève le briquet pour qu'il nous
[Musique]
voit à l'aube l'espoir renais sous la
forme d'un bateau des gardes côte
tur il recueille les migrants pour les
ramener à
terreord
par ok c'est bon on fait comme ça
ils ont sauvé leur vie mais la partie
est loin d'être gagnée le gouvernement
turc n'est pas très tendre avec les
clandestins nous trois Afghans risqu
l'expulsion
immédiate en Sicile Ellie Émile et
Joseph ont fui le camp de rétention sans
attendre leur carte de séjour les
conséquences sont graves ils ont perdu
leur statut de réfugié et sont
maintenant consid clandesttin en Europe
on attend le bus pour aller au port pour
prendre un f cette nuit qui va n
conduire Napoli demain demain
matin ils n'ont qu'une idée en tête
rallier le continent et Paris où ils ont
des contacts et des
amis se problème ils n'ont même pas un
passeport camerounais en
poche
et pour acheter un billet de bateau le
document est
obligatoire une sécurité pour éviter que
des clandestins de kit
Lille mais il y a une faille dans ce
système le cétait le se moyen pour
nousarver à Rome le bateau on demande le
passeport le CR on demande le passeport
l'avion on demande le passeport onait
pas passeport donc le
bus on p juste les tickets donc j'ai un
peu confiance
que la police va pas n
déranger la surprise est énorme le bus
monte sur le Ferri et là personne ne
leur demande de papier tout à l'heure
nous a dit qu' pit pas emprunter le
bateau sans passeport mais subitement je
me retrouve dans un bus dans le bateau
un bus dans le
bateau tu comprends que c'est
surprenant pour aller jusqu'à Rome ils
n'ont sur eux que 125 € de l'argent
récolté grâce à un peu de business dans
le camp et au quelques euros envoyés par
leur
famille le rêve français est enfin àorté
de main
entre Paris et
eux il n'y a plus que 1500 petits
[Musique]
kilomètr
en Turquie le voyage vers l'Europe a
tourné court pour les
Afghans après leur arrestation en mer
ils ont été
[Musique]
emprisonnés au bout de 3
semaines Javid et Rani ont été renvoyés
en
Afghanistan seul deux ont échapper aux
autorités turques le jeune Lukman en
blanc et fawad le chauffeur routier
début juillet nous les retrouvons à
Istanbul et moi on s'en est tiré parce
qu'on a dit qu'on avait 16 ans et demi
du coup on a été envoyé dans un camp
pour
mineur de là on s'est échappé et nous
sommes revenus à
istanbou après plusieurs tentatives raté
de passage en Grèce la filière modifie
l'tinéraire un chement de Co de plus à
leur famille direction la Sicile les
deux afghans la rejoignent cachés dans
un bateau de tourisme de là il gagneent
Rome nous les retrouvons devant le
colisé c'est incroyable j'ai déjà vu ce
monument dans les films j'en ai entendu
parler bien
sûr c'est très vieux ça doit dater d'il
y a 1000 ans au
moins Rome c'est ici que s'arrête le
contrat des
passeurs Lukman et fawad doivent se
débrouiller maintenant tout seul
contrairement aux Africains ils ne se
sont jamais fait raquetter et il leur
reste quelques économies suffisamment
pour rejoindre
Paris de tickets pour le train de 15h
oui oui de
tickets
les TR camerounais ét dans cette même
gare de semaines plus tôt mais n' plus
un
scheous lesiv depu près de mois des li
sont etant déess nous avons chois de le
venir en aide en payant le bill de train
jusquà
Paris
le de amis sont devant t de modernité
ici c'est c'est vraiment
organisé respect le pour ça que c'estile
pour de nous s tellement de monde il y a
tellement
de les clandestins camerounais afghans
ont donc fait le même voyage à quelques
semaines
d'interval de Rome à Paris ils ont pris
les mêmes
trains admirer les même
paysage dorm dans les mêmes
gares
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonjour Vos chef
de bordquip vous souhaite la
bienvenue habill comme des vacanciers
afgan camerounais n' attiré l'attention
d'aucun policier pendant tout leur
[Musique]
trajet enfin nous voici à Paris c'était
notre rêve
maintenant on y
est cette gare est
impressionnante c'est sûrement la plus
grande du
monde maintenant ils vont devoir se
fabriquer une nouvelle
vie et c'est là que tout se complique
les choses ne sont pas aussi simples ni
aussi évidentes qu'il le
[Musique]
pens au début tout le monde est
joyeux un ami d'enfance d'ellit arrivé
il y a 7 ans comme étudiant vient les
accueillir
Ellie va dormir chez lui
[__] longyage jeux pas
imaginer pour Joseph aussi tout
s'enchaîne bien oui nous sommes à
macader actuellement là à un vieux
copain valallé berger MAAD don il y a
trop de bouchon sur la r mais il est en
train d'arriver ici
le seul à rester sur le carreau c'est
Émile aucune de ses connaissance à Paris
ne veut
l'accueillir super
Dieu super
Dieu j'ai beaucoup de personnes qui ont
refusé de me
recevoir je ne croyais pas que je
pouvais Erer comme ça par alors que j'ai
les
gens er le copain
t de lui trouver une solution au moins
pour la
nuit
jeapp
cous
[Musique]
dormir Émile peut souffler pour
l'instant ce soir il aura un toit mais
demain quand nous avons arrêté le
tournage Émile Ellie et Joseph les trois
camerounais n'ét plus hébergés par
personne de le côté se sont dirig ver la
Seu adresse qu'il
connaiss parisien bien Conn de le
compatri on voir du monde qu'on
connare
fam AF eu aussi ont vite déchanter la
vie de réfugié à Paris est loin d'être
celle qu'il imagin il n'y a pas de
travail et personne pour les
aider heureusement leur nouveau copains
leur livr le mode d'emploi pour survivre
dans la jungle
parisienne si tu veux manger tu dois
faire le tour des mosquées tu fais tes
ablutionses TR prières et tuuras
le matin quand ce parc va ouvrir tu fais
quoi à ton avis et ben tu vas te
chercher un tapis et des cartons et tu
vas les poser ici ton sac sera ton
oreiller et tu dormiras juste pour ne
pas penser on sait jamais où on va
manger le
lendemain notre situation est tellement
mauvaise moi ça fait 2 ans que je suis
ici et j'ai pas encore envoyé un centime
au
pays on m'avait dit qu'à Paris des
hélicoptères aspergaient du parfum sur
la
ville mais dès que je suis arrivé j'ai
compris que c'était pire que dalalabad
ma ville natale en
Afghanistan je n'aurais jamais pensé que
c'était comme
ça on m'avait dit qu'à mon arrivée
j'aurais tout garde
l'est et puis là je vois des gens
beaucoup plus malheureux que moi
alors je fais quoi je reste ou je
rentre la nuit le SIR ferme ses portes
lman et fawad partag le sort des Afghans
de
Paris quand je suis arrivé à Paris je
croyais que le gouvernement allait nous
aider et ici je vois mes frères afghans
dormir dans la
rue et mon rêve est totalement
brisé 4 mois après son départ du
Pakistan lman a dans Paris en enchaînant
les centres d'hébergement et la rue mais
il apprend le français dans une
[Musique]
association dégoûté fawad a préféré
tenter sa chance en
Allemagne làbas il s'est fait
interpeller il attend aujourd'hui que la
allemande décide de son
[Musique]
sort